at the start of a game of Thrones there
haven't been dragons in the world for
quite some time they are believed to be
extinct by the vast majority of people
although there are rumors of dragons
still living within the shadow east of
ash I at the end of the game of Thrones
Daenerys Targaryen somehow hatches three
dragon eggs by putting them on the
funeral pyre with her dead husband and
walking into the pyre herself only to
remain unharmed when the fire dies down
why did the nearest do what she did and
why did it work
as the game of Thrones goes on to
nearest becomes gradually more obsessed
with her stone dragon eggs when Danny
goes into labor she nearly dies and goes
in and out of consciousness for several
days once they find her on the carpet
crawling towards her dragon eggs
I must she tried to tell them I have to
sleep princess sadawa said no Danny said
please please yes he covered her with
silk though she was burning sleep and
grow struggling in Khaleesi come back to
us the next time Danny wakes she asked
for one of her dragon eggs she seems to
know that she feels heat within it and
something moves within the stone however
Danny is not afraid it did not frighten
her all her fear was gone but under way
after Danny wakes for the final time she
finds Drogo catatonic and her son
stillborn she mercy kills Drogo and
punishes myriad master for tricking her
by tying her to Khal Drogo's funeral
pyre where she is also placed her three
dragon eggs before Danny lets the fire
the major declares you will not hear me
scream I will Danny said but it is not
your screams I will only your life I
remember what he told me only death can
pay for life marry Maz Duur
opened her mouth but she made no reply
as she stepped away Danny saw that the
contempt was gone from the mages black
black eyes in its place was something
that might have been fear what happens
when Danny herself steps into the pyre
is key the flames were so beautiful the
loveliest things she had ever seen each
one a sorcerer robed in yellow and
orange and scarlet swirling long smoky
cloaks Danny seems to be entranced by
the flames as she walks further into the
fire her clothes begin to burn off but
she herself is not burned she hears a
crack and she sees one of the Dragons
eggs fall to the ground cracked open and
smoldering she thinks to herself only
death can pay for life and then another
crack loud and sharp as thunder she can
hear screaming from outside of the pyre
she hears Jorah calling for her she
thinks to herself
the fire is mine I am Daenerys Stormborn
the daughter of dragons ride dragons
mother of dragons don't you see finally
here she hears a third crack loud and
sharp as the breaking of the world the
pirate collapses what happens after that
is history as they say but how how did
Danny hatch dragon eggs the Valyrians
tamed and controlled dragons through
magic that has been lost in time all the
leering and magic is said to be rooted
in fire and blood Drogo spire had both
when Danny life the pyre the flames
engulf Miriam as door and she goes
silent it's only then that Danny's
dragon eggs begin to crack and even then
Danny thinks in that moment only death
can pay for life was the mages life part
of the sacrifice that allowed Dany's
dragons to be born I think this is
likely and Daenerys seems to think so
but still that doesn't explain how Danny
survived the fire in the show Danny
seems to be immune to fire but in the
book she's not she's burned several
times throughout the course of the
series and george RR martin himself has
flat-out stated that she's not immune so
how does Danny not burn I believe the
answer lies again in Meereen as door
before the pyre is lit marry Maz Duur
proclaims that Dany will not hear her
scream and when the fire is lit she
begins to sing in a shrill allyou lating
voice similar to the way she did in
Drobo's 10 marry Mazda voice to a high
elating well that sent a shiver down
down his back some of the Dothraki begin
to mutter and back away the tent was
aglow with the light of Bray's ears
within through blood splattered sad silk
she glimpsed shadows moving merry Mazda
was dancing and not alone
could it be that Miriah was trying to
prevent herself from burning by
performing some type of spell and is it
possible that for some reason instead of
saving her from burning and saved Danny
some Targaryen so though not immune
seems to possess a higher tolerance to
heat than most as evidenced by Danny's
fondness and taking extremely hot baths
that most people would find unbearable
could this plus Miri spell have been
what allowed Danny to survive the fire
but not Miri the final thing to consider
here is King's blood there are some
evidence throughout the series that
Kings blood covers a certain magical
properties this is mostly perpetuated by
Melisandre but there is possible
connection here and Milla Saunders
religion the combination of Kings blood
and fire could have potent magical
effects Drogo's blood could have been
key in the hatching of Danny's dragons
Danny is certainly not the first
Targaryen after the extinction to
attempt to hatch new dragon eggs the
most well known and recent attempt other
than Danny's led to a horrible tragedy
Danny's great-grandfather Aegon v was a
just king who cared for the poor as he
grew older he became more and more
obsessed with the idea of hatching
dragons the last years of his reign were
consumed by a search for lore about
dragon breeding in Valyria it's said
that he commissioned journeys to places
as far away as a shy in the hopes of
finding some forgotten knowledge all of
this leads up to the tragedy at summer
hall the blood of the dragon gathered in
1:7 eggs to honor seven gods though
King's own Septon had warned pyrrol
masses wildfire flames grew out of
control towering burns so hot that died
but for the valor of Lord command it
seems like at summer hall Eglin was
attempting to hatch dragon eggs but
something went terribly wrong and
everyone there ends up dying well not
everyone some do survive Targaryen
seemed to have a habit of doing that
they become obsessed with fire and
Dragons and they usually end up killing
themselves like Danny probably would
have if Mary Maz Duur hadn't been there
Danny simply had all the right pieces in
all the right places at exactly the
right time she appears to have
unknowingly performed an ancient ritual
which led to the birth of her
it's almost as if destiny was guiding
her or perhaps something else as seems
as though something was reaching out to
Danny through her dreams attempting to
influence her the first dream Danny had
comes days before her wedding to Drogo
and when examined it seems like an
attempt to scare Daenerys the series was
hitting her hurting her she was naked
clumsy with fear she ran from him but
her body seemed thick and ungainly he
struck her again she stumbled and fell
you woke the dragon he screamed as he
kicked her you woke the dragon you woke
the dragon her thighs were slick with
blood she closed her eyes and whimpered
as if an answer there was a hideous
ripping sound in the crackling of some
great fire when she looked again the
series was gone
great columns of flame rose all around
and in the midst of them was the dragon
it turned its great head slowly when its
molten eyes found her she woke shaking
and covered with a fine sheen of sweat
she had never been so afraid
Danny's second dream however seems to be
one of an empowering nature yet when she
slept that night she dripped the dragon
dream again the series was not in it
this time there was only her and the
dragon if scales were blackest night wet
and slick with blood her blood
Danny sensed its eyes were pools of
molten magma and when it opened its
mouth the flame came roaring out in a
hot jet she could hear it singing to her
she opened her arms to the fire embraced
it let it swallow her whole let it
cleanse her and temper her and scour her
clean she could feel the flesh SIA and
blacken and slaw away she could feel her
blood boil and turned to steam yet there
was no pain she felt strong and new and
fierce there seems to be a conflict
between the tone of the two dreams while
one encouraged two nearest to fear the
dragon the other encourages two nearest
to embrace the dragon the final
is a mixture of the two she's walking
towards the red door walking fast trying
to get to it the red door if you don't
know represents home for Daenerys she
hears in her head you don't want to wake
the dragon do you she dreams of making
love to Drogo under a blue sky with a
dragon flying above and she sees it
setting the world aflame she hears again
don't want to wake the dragon do you she
sees Jorah sorrowful face and hears him
call Rhaegar the last dragon again she
hears don't want to wake the dragon then
she sees Viserys screaming at her she
sees a horrible image of his eyes
bursting open and running down his
cheeks again the voice don't want to
wake the dragon now here's where it gets
even more interesting the red door was
so far ahead of her she could feel the
icy breath behind sweeping up on her if
it caught her she would die a death that
was more than death howling forever
alone in the darkness she began to run
don't want to wake the dragon
as Danny's dream goes on the image of
CeCe's become less and less pleasant as
she gives in to fear she is desperately
afraid of the icy breath behind her so
she runs faster towards the red door
next she sees ray go her son that never
was
he smiled but when he opens his mouth
flames come out kind of like a dragon
she hears the voice again but this time
it says what to wake the dragon she
finally catches up to the red dwarf
Ling's it open she hears the voice one
last time the dragon within the house
she sees Rhaegar but when she lifts his
visor it's her face she then wakes I
think it's pretty symbolic that Danny
finds herself within Rhaegar it's simple
stuff like that that keeps me from
buying into certain popular theories in
the asado bison fire community let's
just keep it at that firmly delusional
but it's almost like we just witnessed
some type of battle here one that's of a
very abstract nature and very strange on
the surface almost as though two forces
are pulling Danny in two different
directions one encouraging and
empowering the other disparaging and
frightening if there are opposing forces
representative of fire and ice as Milla
Sandra's religion seems to suggest then
it makes sense that they will be at
constant odds but based on what george
RR martin has said in the past it seems
unlikely that these forces or gods would
manifest in such a direct way so it's
more likely that people would be behind
Danny's dreams a dragon would be the
obvious champion of fire dragons are
fire made flesh much in the same way the
others seem to be ice made flesh so any
champion of ice probably wouldn't want
dragons around and would probably
actively try to prevent dragons from
coming into being assuming that they
have the ability to of course who could
these people be well one of the people
that we know that can injure the dreams
of people is Bloodraven also known as
the three-eyed crow also known as
Brendan River
now the book does say that wings shadow
denier is a steve-o dream where these
the wings of a dragon or the wings of
the three-eyed crow now honestly it
seems to me that Bloodraven is a
prisoner of the children of the forest
think about it for one second
bloodraven couldn't leave that cave if
he tried he is a part of the weirwood
blood Raven was known to study the
arcane arts could it be that he was
lured into the cave by the children by
the promise of learning old knowledge
and gaining new powers and they used him
as their thrall since until he grew old
and began to wither so they had to call
forth a new victim if the children of
the forest and the others are in league
as I have suggested in other videos then
it makes sense that they would do
everything they could to try and prevent
the birth of dragons as we know the
others use reanimated corpses of men as
their thralls
the most definite way to kill one of
these souls is by fire dragons would
seem to be the perfect weapon against
the others one the children of the
forest and the others are working
together into mankind to the children of
the forest have the ability to send
dreams influencing the mind of people
through bloodraven as evidenced by Jojen
and bran three dragons will be the
ultimate bane of the others all the
pieces seem to fit through Bloodraven
the children have been manipulating key
characters in our story some to greater
effect than others and what if I told
you that it's been going on for far
longer than either brand or Gani have
even been alive but wait so if
Bloodraven is behind Danny's
discouraging fearful dreams then who
could be behind the empowering ones well
you'll have to watch part two to find
out thank you guys for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
ideas of Ice and Fire